bonjour dans mon épisode 2 de chroniques
de proches avaient brièvement mentionné
les maladies au moyen-âge mais c'était
l'épisode 2 j'étais jeune et innocente
dit surtout que je n'ai pas encore eu le
temps d'apprendre la vie et la mort en
l'occurrence puisque aujourd'hui on va
parler de la peste noire qui était
plutôt de mortels d'ailleurs je traîne
une petite fièvre depuis que je suis
arrivé ici
humour c'est parti
[Musique]
la peste noire qui débarque dans nos
contrées en 1347 n'est pas la première
épidémie qui connut les européens ils
avaient déjà l'habitude de la rougeole
la variole la petite vérole ces maladies
étaient récurrentes mais ce qui est sûr
vivait restait immunisé donc logiquement
il ne tombait malade qu'une fois
par contre la maladie est resté en deux
ce qui explique que les natifs
américains étaient décimées lorsque les
européens ont découvert l'amérique
mais en échange ils nous ont
probablement filet la syphilis parmi les
maladies dont on a connaissance on peut
aussi citer la peste anthony vers 165
qui fait des ravages dans l' empire
romain d'après sa description par de
nombreux auteurs et notamment le médecin
gallien qui l'a soigné il pourrait en
fait s'agir de la variole en 541
l'europe connaît sa première pandémie
avec la peste de justinien qui revient
par cycle jusqu'aux année 760 et
provoque un effondrement démographique
dans l'empiré romain d'orient
cette fois on est sûr qu'il s'agissait
de la peste bubonique grâce à des
squelettes sur lesquels on a retrouvé
l'adn de yersinia pestis on peut aussi
mentionner la lettre qui est très connu
et déjà cité dans la bible cependant on
n'est pas certain qu'elle ait existé en
europe occidentale avant l'apparition de
la peste dans les léproseries qui ont
été fouillés
très peu de squelettes présente les
déformations osseuses dû à la peste il
est donc possible que le terme de lèpre
et est utilisé pour recouvrir tout un
tas de maladies vers 1300 les européens
ont donc l'habitude d'épidémie
récurrentes et ont déjà connu quelques
bonnes grosse épidémie ou enfin la peste
de justinien remonte à cinq siècles
alors excuses nous mais on n'en avait
pas vraiment un souvenir très précis non
plus certes de plus à cette époque la
densité humaine en europe occidentale
était très forte
du coup on crée de plus en plus de champ
pour cultiver mais les sols étaient
épuisés le rendement en grain dcri née
les récoltes étaient insuffisantes et
donc souvent c'était la famille voilà
pour le contexte
en plus c'était le début de la petite
aire glaciaire qui dure du 13e au 19e
siècle
donc on avait faim et on avait froid
mais on n'était pas encore malade alors
tout va bien oui bah justement on y
vient passons maintenant aux années 1340
là où tout commence
les premières peste que j'ai cité la
peste de justinien notamment venaient
d'afrique la peste noire vient
d'ailleurs d'asie les plus précisément
de mongolie dans cette région on trouve
différentes espèces de marmottes qui
pourraient avoir été les porteuses des
puces pestis
et on parle de puces qui résiste à des
températures de moins 25 degrés et à des
jeunes de dix mois moi ce sont donc les
nemesis des européens qui en cette
période je le rappelle avait faim et
froid à partir de 1320 la peste se
déclare en mongolie et en chine et fait
déjà des ravages mais n'est pas encore
transmises aux européens pourtant à
partir des années 1960 des liens
s'étaient noués des marchands génois se
rendent en asie coucou marco polo et
comment ce tracé d'une nouvelle route
terrestre jusqu'à la chine qu'on appelle
par la suite la route de la soie sur
cette route se trouve l'étape de la tan
a une petite ville fouillés en 1885 dans
cette ville on a découvert que dans les
années 1330 8339 il y avait eu beaucoup
de morts et sur trois pierres tombales
il était carrément écrit que les
personnes était morte de la peste
la tan a pourrait donc être le village à
partir duquel la peste se répand en
europe puisqu'il menait ensuite à café
ou les genôts avait établi un comptoir
marchand en 1345 la ville de kafa est
assiégée par les troubles via nydegg un
chèque mongols pas de chance pour lui
ses troupes ont la peste une anecdote
raconte que yani bègue aurait catapulté
ces morts par dessus les murailles de
kafa ce qui en ferait un premier cas de
guerre bactériologique
mais il est plus probable que la peste
soit juste passer du camp siège à la
ville
et comme il s'agissait d'une ville
marchande elle a ensuite eu tout le
loisir de contaminer le reste de
l'europe plaisir d'offrir joie de
recevoir en octobre 1347 un bateau
génois acosta messine mais pas de bol
pour lui ces marins sont soit morts soit
mourant et comme on n'a pas encore trop
compris le truc surtout qu'on est en
octobre et qu'à l'époque les épidémies
étaient rares en hiver ça continue en
1348 la peste arrive à marseille et
s'étend ensuite par voie terrestre
elle touche la france entière puis les
pays-bas franchi la manche puis voyage
en norvège en suède en 1350 elle s'est
étendue jusqu'en écosse aux arcades aux
iles féroé shetland et même jusqu'en
islande et au groenland et finalement
c'est pas vraiment de quel virus il
s'agissait ni si c'était vraiment la
peine
fake chronique aux les médias nous
manque cette peste a disparu au début du
xviiie siècle en europe
alors on n'est sûr de rien d'après les
descriptions qu'on en fait les
chroniqueurs il pourrait aussi s'agir de
l'anthrax de la tuberculose de la
typhoïde ou du typhus
la teste et transmises par des rongeurs
pour qu'il y ait épidémie il faut que
les rongeurs meurt et que leurs puces
migrent vers les humains
or certains chroniqueurs musulmans et
chinois parle de mort massive de rats
mais aucun européen
de plus la peste bubonique mais deux à
huit jours à incuber ses cours ce qui ne
devrait pas laisser le temps à un malade
de voyager de ville en ville pour
contaminer le reste de la population
mystère donc il existe trois types de
tests principaux est exceptionnellement
là je mettrai pas d'illustration la
peste bubonique d'abord laisse 25 à 30%
de chances de survie elle n'est pas
transmissible entre les hommes mais
seulement par les puces les rats et donc
on en revient à la même question est ce
que c'était vraiment ça il existe aussi
la peste pulmonaire lorsque les massifs
se trouve dans les poumons et celle ci
est transmissible entre hommes grâce aux
crachats de liquide présent dans les
poumons
elle tue dans 95% des cas tu peux faire
la dernière la peste septicémique et la
dernière catégorie
lorsque le bas si entre dans le sang
elle provoque l'éclatement des vaisseaux
sanguins et toujours mortelle quoi qu'il
en soit on ignore de quel poste il
s'agissait il pourrait s'agir d'un virus
mutant même d'une mutation humaines du
coup notre population descendrait d'une
souche immunisés contre la peste les
contemporains de la peste s'interroge
aussi sur ses origines mais ils ne vont
pas vraiment cherché dans le domaine
médical il se tourne vers l'astrologie
ou encore des tremblements de terre ou
des éruptions volcaniques qui aurait
déchiré la terre est libéré des vapeurs
mortels
ici le tremblement de terre de mal en
1356 qu'ils accusent aussi les groupes
de personnes les juifs parce qu'il y
avait beaucoup de médecins juifs à
l'époque alors vous c'est suspect mais
aussi les étrangers des tanneurs les
bouchers et des prostituées les
homosexuels c'est la grande paranoïa
heureusement que la société a évolué
depuis puisque toutes ces accusations ne
mène pas à grand chose
étonnamment on va aussi chercher la
réponse dans les livres on commence par
la bible dedans on trouve les sept
plaies d'égypte mais aussi les plaies
envoyé par dieu aux israélites pendant
leur errance à chaque fois qu'ils
refusent d'obéir aux prêtres sur votre
arrêt de travail je mets punition divine
et quand me retenant souffrait
repentance et prierait beaucoup ça fera
10 livres selon les médecins il est
clair qu'ils s'intéressent à la peste
elle ne cible même pas une personne
coupable mais toute une population
contrairement à la lettre qui était
considéré comme une punition divine
individuel durant les premiers temps de
l'apparition de la peste on s'intéresse
donc beaucoup à ces causes mais peu à la
manière de la soigner il existait
pourtant de chouettes traité datant de
l'antiquité comme un traité de thucydide
sur la peste d'athènes mais ils sont peu
étudiés
du côté de lorient on s'en sort un petit
peu mieux alors que l'occident a
complètement délaissé d'antiquités
depuis un moment
lorient conserve encore certains traités
et a connaissance des pieds limite peste
datant du 7e ou 8e siècle par exemple
les musulmans considèrent qu'il vaut
mieux éviter de quitter ou de se rendre
dans un endroit pestiférés alors qu'en
occident on a plutôt tendance à se
barrer le plus vite possible et donc à
contaminer les autres
la peste touche surtout les villes
certaines plus que d'autres sans qu'on
sache toujours pourquoi
à moscou la première épidémie tu 31% de
la population
60 % à venise 40% à milan qui impose vie
des restrictions à l'entrée de la ville
en moyenne les pertes dans les villes
sont de 40%
le grand duc de moscou et le patriarche
de l'église orthodoxe ont tué ainsi que
le roi alphonse 9 de castille qui est le
seul droit européen à mourir de la peste
ça a dû faire pester le problème c'est
que la grande mort ou grandes pestilence
comme on l'appelle à l'époque n'a pas
fait que frapper une fois elle frappe
vers 1350 mhz et revient ensuite en 1361
où elle tue à nouveau 20 % de la
population
puis vers 1370 où elle reçut 10 à 15% de
la population jusqu'à la fin du xvème
siècle elle revient tous les 6 à 12 ans
touchant encore une fois surtout les
villes du coup la société n'a jamais
temps de se relever jusqu'à 1500 un
individu est exposé deux à quatre fois à
la peste au cours de sa vie après cette
date les épidémies s'espacent tous les
quinze ou vingt ans tout de même
mais reste tout aussi meurtrière à cause
de ces épidémies ponctuelle les
dirigeants des villans ont tendance à
partir vers la campagne ce qui provoque
parfois des émeutes chez ceux qui
restent
les dernières grandes apparition de
cette peste sont en 1665 à londres où
20% de la population et tu es là encore
de nombreux habitants quittent la ville
surtout des riches le roi évidemment
mais bon heureusement l'église trouve le
coupable
la république de cromwell allait pas
déconner avec la monarchie et on vous
l'avait dit et puis pas de bol un an
plus tard a lieu le grand incendie de
londres de 1666 fallait vraiment pas
déconner heureusement on finit par
comprendre certaines choses sur la peste
et à mener des actions un poil plus
efficace que la prière collective
on commence à avoir recours à des
quarantaines à des certificats de bonne
santé améliorer l'hygiène des villes et
les villes italiennes surtout sont très
en avance sur les autres
elle se met rapidement à communiquer
entre elles même en temps de guerre et
impose des certificats de bonne santé
avant d'entrer dans les villes ont créé
de nouvelles structures pour mettre en
quarantaine les hommes les marchandises
et les bateaux et dans certaines villes
on impose aux familles de déclarer leur
décès et parfois même d'en donner la
cause lorsqu'il y à un mort dans une
famille des personnels spécialisés
vienne le chercher et ses biens sont
brûlés les familles de la victime se
retrouve alors enfermé soit chez elle
soit dans une maison pestiférés on
appelle aussi lazaret il faut donc
imaginer que dans une ville atteinte par
la peste on avait des tas de familles
qui était enfermée chez elle à attendre
que ça se passe ou que ça passe pas
d'ailleurs l'état est obligé d nourrir
évidemment ce qui coûte super cher et
comme ces personnes ne travaillent pas
pendant l'épidémie
elle ne paye pas d'impôts donc c'est la
misère heureusement certaines personnes
font parfois des dons à seville ou alors
on crée d impôt spécial peste comme à
lille à la fin du moyen-âge l'italie est
très en avance sur le traitement de la
peste et l'angleterre un peu en retard
en france des règlements spéciaux sont
mis en place et des hôpitaux sont
construites comme l'hôpital saint louis
vers 1610 là encore l'italie était en
avance l'hôpital de milan et si à
l'écran est construit en 1488 et pouvait
accueillir seize mille malades
on ne vous gâche pas qu'ils étaient un
peu serré les deux seins faisait surtout
de la prévention mais peu de thérapie et
de toute façon il n'était pas très
efficace commence à ma thérapie n'est
pas efficace un petit remède à base de
vinaigre et d'oignons ça nous remet sur
pied si vraiment ça ne passe pas on
pourra tester le mercure ou l'arsenic
j'ai aussi un petit élixir à
de buman scorpions qui vient d'arriver
par contre resté loin c'est mieux merci
parfois malgré les mesures en place sa
mère d c'est le cas de la dernière
grande épidémie de peste à marseille en
1720 le 31 janvier 1720 un bateau quitte
si don avec un certificat de santé en
bonne forme mais après ensuite fait la
teste s'y est déclarée quelques jours
après son départ il connaît quelques
morts en cours de route et s'attend à
être mis en quarantaine à marseille
mais ce n'est pas le cas d'autres
bateaux continuent d'arriver du
moyen-orient alors que la peste y fait
rage et on les laisse des charges est
tranquillement non mais franchement ça
ressemblait pas à la peste et je me
connais les autorités commencent à
s'inquiéter et décide de déplacer tout
ce beau monde sur l'île de jaar là où on
mettait les personnes en quarantaine
mais c'est un peu tard
on commence à se rendre compte qu'une
épidémie couvent on essaye de couvrir un
peu les choses en parlant de mort
suspecte et en déplaçant les malades de
nuit les habitantes sont pas qu'au et
comme on passe en juillet à environ 350
morts par jour il s'emploie aussi bon on
peut reconnaître aux médecins que la
plupart restent en ville pour soigner
les malades
merci pour moi quand même comme beaucoup
d'épidémie celle ci provoque
l'endettement de la ville des problèmes
de ravitaillement l'ouverture d'hôpitaux
on propose à des galériens d'être libéré
pour débarrasser les rues des morts
puisque en août on passe à mille morts
par jour il ne devait pas être d'une
forme olympique coi de marseille le
savon dont l'olympique du coup les gens
sortent de chez eux avec des bâtons de
saint roch
les bâtons de deux mètres de long qui
leur servent à marc avait la gueule des
passants qui risquerait de les toucher
juste à les tenir éloignés
en septembre la situation semble se
calmer les riches revienne mais juste à
ce moment là la teste frappe le quartier
riche de la ville loi de murphy
bonjour finalement vers octobre
l'épidémie se calme vraiment on brûle
les tissus des personnes décédées au mur
les cryptes des églises qui avait servi
de cimetière
c'était quand même un beau bordel qui
aurait pu être évitée si la quarantaine
avaient été appliquées dès le départ ce
qui aurait permis à 56% de la population
de ne pas décédée évidemment toutes ces
mesures pour éviter la teste n'était pas
parfaitement efficace sinon il y aurait
peut-être plus d'épidémie mais elle
montre une modernisation des états en
matière de santé avec le début des
inspections sanitaires et de
l'enregistrement des décès comme dans
tout processus de modernisation il ya
aussi des résistances certaines
personnes
r le remords pour les réenterrer dans le
cimetière familial ou encore les
fossoyeurs son deck parce que d'habitude
ils gardaient le plus beau vêtement de
la personne décédée est là en cas de
peste ils sont brûlés la peste noire a
des tas de conséquences sur la société
plus ou moins directe est évidente
emploi le marché du travail s'effondre
et le temps d'apprentissage d'un métier
et diminuées afin que l'apprenti ne
meurt pas avant d'avoir terminé religion
avant la peste de la formation du clergé
s'était élevé beaucoup étaient allés à
l'université mais à cause de la première
vague de peste le niveau général
d'éducation des prêtres diminue pendant
plusieurs dizaines d'années un prêtre
sur 10 abandonne son poste parce que ça
va bien des conneries on manque
d'ailleurs tellement de prêtres que
l'évêque de basse écrit en 1349 qu'une
personne qui se sent partir peut se
confesser à n'importe qui même une femme
en allemagne apparaissent des
flagellants des types qui se déplacent
en bandes font des rondes en chantant
autour des églises puis se jette par
terre pour se flageller c'est une autre
culture écologie grâce ou à cause de la
désertification des campagnes les loups
agrandissent leur territoire et arrive
dans les faubourgs de paris vers 1420
agriculture puisqu'il ya moins besoin de
nourriture
bah oui tout le monde est mort les
paysans se diversifient par exemple dans
le bétail et créent de nouvelles
inventions pour remplacer la main
d'oeuvre disparu mode certains produits
comme la soie deviennent plus faciles à
trouver et à cause du bouleversement de
la société certaines lois somptuaires
sont mises en place pour empêcher des
personnes de s'habiller au dessus de
leurs rangs parce que ça plaisait pas
trop aux nobles devoirs des pays core
s'habiller comme art les représentations
de danse macabre sont graves à la mode
santé une forte suspicion à l'égard des
médecins subsiste jusqu'à de nos jours
société les gens vont davantage au
cabaret et se bourrer la gueule en
pensant à epicure la peste noire la
deuxième pandémie prend fin au xviiie
siècle la troisième pandémie éclate en
asie un canton en 1894 et ne touche que
lorient elle atteint hong kong l'inde
on trouve quelques cas aussi en
australie en afrique du sud et au
portugal à cause de ces dames
commerciaux avec l'asie + 3 cas à vienne
qui sont un peu what the fuck cette
peste disparaît en 1948 après avoir fait
12 millions de victimes
et grâce à elle le bacterial og
alexandre hier signe parvient à isoler
le bacille de la peste à l'identifier et
à produire un ses rôles et à lui donner
son nom merci à pestis ça ne s'invente
pas de nos jours on trouve encore
quelques cas de
peste bubonique tous les angles qui sont
rarement mortelle mais la peste ne
figure donc parmi les maladies
totalement éradiquée contrairement à la
variole qui a été reconnue éradiquée en
1990 seulement et on ne sait pas de
telles épidémies pourrait réapparaître
quand on voit les réactions des médias
et du public face à certains début
d'épidémie comme la peste à bombay en
1990 où le strass en asie en 2003 on
voit bien que la menace d'une grande
épidémie mortelle fait peur surtout si
elle vient d'afrique ou d'asie et si
elle risque de toucher les occidentaux
ta vie tu as pris mine de rien cette
peur des maladies est d'autant plus
grande que certaines nous sont
transmises par d'autres animaux
on partage des pathologies avec de
nombreux animaux et le cas de la vache
folle par exemple fait peur justement
parce qu'elle est transmise des bovins à
l'homme pendant sait pas grand chose et
qu'elle résiste aux traitements
c'est un cas comme celui-là qui laisse à
penser que certaines maladies peuvent
être dus à des virus mutants
c'était peut-être le cas de la teste
noir et peut-être qu'elle a disparu
d'ailleurs aussi à cause d'une mutation
celle des x men
j'étais sur une feinte sérieuse la bon
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère que vous ne pas trop
démoralisés et je vous promets que la
prochaine parlera d'un sujet un petit
peu plus joyeux en attendant n'allait
pas sur doctissimo
si vous avez eu peur après cette vidéo
portez vous bien aussi j'en profite pour
dire parce que ça fait un moment la
chaîne existe depuis plus de deux ans et
je ne suis pas présentée en fait donc on
ne pourrait faire une faq pour être une
idée et si vous avez des questions à
poser
posez les dans les commentaires et j'y
répondrai prochainement dans une faq
voilà à bientôt
et face à la musique chez nous
by way we were keep you gardère nommé
[Musique]
smart tank
vous me croirez qu'enfin nous bénisse et
aux maladies aux malades cela est émis
[Musique]
comment nous faire le pain de mie pas
folle seniors i work yoga de 9h mustapha
[Musique]
matériaux sains